Hey, what's going on as bill burn? It's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 10th,
2014 how you're doing?
How I um,
I am in a country mood this week and I
have deaf desperately trying to bring
something positive. All right. I've been
on the road here for 10 fucking days.
I was going to do this
thing with Versie again,
but he's still sleeping and I got to
get this thing up and get on with my day
cause I got a two hour ride out to London,
Ontario tonight and I
got a fucking job to do.
I'm in the middle of a fucking eight
day run kit, you know, seven days.
Then I got Montreal tomorrow
and then I got a day off.
I got a fucking day off and I'm going
to go to the Bruins Canadians game.
And um,
you know,
I have a great fucking time
cause you can hear my voice is a,
it's actually better. It doesn't sound
better, but it's actually better.
It's holding up.
Well,
today is the halfway point
of the epic 20 Day Canadian.
Tor. Tor. Tor, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Um,
we're having a great time up here.
Um, probably too much fun. Uh,
um, off the wagon as of last
Monday. Um, but you know,
I only got fucked up twice this week.
You know,
I got really fucked up about two nights
ago, but other than that, and uh, I,
I didn't miss being hung over.
So for the most part,
like last night I had a beer two nights
before that I had one glass of wine.
I mean,
if you want to call that,
if you want to call that ticky
tack shit drinking. All right?
You want to sit there with your fucking
toes pointed at each other and your
knees together.
Right?
Like some fucking jerk off waiting for a
bus in a Norman Rockwell painting then,
then you, you do that. All
right. I don't count those. Okay.
For what I heard a glass of wine
every day is actually good for you.
Fucking arteries.
Race.
Yeah.
Oh, you hear that somebody finally
committed a crime up here in Canada.
What did he do? Did he put on
somebody else's skates? Oh,
sorry about that. Sorry. I like these
people up here. Everybody says, sorry,
I say sorry all the time. You know,
hey, there's this pancake you made.
Tastes like a fucking, somebody
wiped her ass with it. Sorry.
I'm sorry you didn't, you suck
it. Make it a pancake. Right.
Um,
I actually had an apple for breakfast.
If you're wandering trying to stay
in shape when I'm up here now,
it was kitten who, I'm not going to
lie to you guys. I am fucking shot. I,
I've been just traveling and doing
my God damn act every fucking night.
I am so sick of my God damn voice,
which is great because it's making me
say new stuff on stage and I've been
writing a lot. Now I'm not saying
that I actually sit down and write.
What I'm really saying is I'm just
saying different shit on stage and um,
you know, it was a lot of shit. Jokes,
flooded Dick Jokes. But you know,
I'm getting through it. It's been a,
it's been amazing. Absolutely amazing.
We're on a four day run here in a,
in Toronto and the Greater Toronto area.
Uh, we started off down in, uh,
I don't even know what the Fuck Hammer
Ville Hammerstein I don't know what it is,
but the nickname is fucking ham.
Hamilton.
The nickname is hammertime stop.
Hammertime Doo Doo doot doot boop boop.
Um,
was unbelievable.
Great fucking show down there.
And then I also found out for a buddy
of mine that around the corner was a,
with at that unreal team. Canada
game was in 1987 when they, uh,
when they beat the Russians
Gretzky Lemieux right?
You guys,
were you guys member D of fucking member?
Um, I died, let's see,
I played a pickup game,
a hockey and Ottawa. That was great. Me
and verse, he skated on the frozen canal.
We held hands and split a beaver tail
and whispered sweet nothings into one
another's ears. We didn't get a beaver
tail, but the rest of it happens.
All right, then I stand by it. No, we,
uh, we did skate on the canal, man.
It's fucking unbelievable.
Ottawa. Underrated. Brutally,
brutally,
brutally fucking underrated.
You want to surprise your girlfriend
or soon to be wife with a honeymoon.
She'll never forget or
possibly forgive you for,
take her to Ottaway everybody.
It's a government town.
Did you guys know that Ottawa is the
capital of Canada? I didn't know that.
It's one of those towns.
Everybody's got the big government job
and right around five everybody takes off
and even the Starbucks closes.
But if you go across the fucking river
is a bunch of places to get yourself a
beer.
It was a little a rink out here.
I Dunno, it's guys I got, I
have absolutely nothing. Um,
I'm too old to be on tour this long.
And uh, today's the halfway point.
So I got another 10 days and I'm
out of the 10 days to go on this.
Last night I was at our Massey
Hall. For those of you who, um,
never heard of it. Um, if you favorite
band has ever played a show there,
it's worth taking a trip. Unbelievable.
Second I walked out there,
I was saying diversity like Jesus Christ.
I'd love to take a special here.
But then I heard, um, I heard their fees
as through the fucking roof. Of course.
You know, like I'm the only asshole that
walked in there and said, you know what,
I said, this will look visually
look really good on Cuba. Um,
but uh,
yeah,
it was definitely a very humbling to be
on that thing because I kind of looked
up some of the history before I got
out there and evidently one night,
miles Davis,
Charlie Parker,
Charles Mingus and fucking Max Roach
put on arguably one of the greatest
concerts of all time.
Louie Armstrong played there.
I'm not a big rush fan,
but I guess that uh,
all the world's a stage they
filmed there are recorded there.
Neil young recorded some stuff there and
then old Billy red face came in and did
he shit and Dick Jokes.
I had some guy after the show told me
that he saw George Carlin performed there
in the 80s. So it was definitely, uh,
it was pretty awesome to become a,
I don't know,
part of that history there. Uh,
I'm definitely fucking coming back.
So here's the deal. So at the
end of the show, you know,
versus he wants to go see that fucking
movie where somebody is getting murdered
on a plane every 10 minutes.
And for some reason they can't figure
out who the fuck's doing it. Okay.
And I'm sitting here having this
argument with first he's going to,
I'm not going to go see that shit.
And he's like, he's like, dude,
it's fucking Liam Neeson, Liam Neeson
Nizam, whatever the fuck you say his name.
And I'm like, I liked that guy. Okay.
But snakes on a plane
is snakes on a plane,
even if there's no snakes on the plane.
You know what I mean? It is what it is.
It's fucking still good.
And I know somebody going to shoot
a gun on the plane, you know?
And somehow, even if
he misses it, I dunno,
just, it's fucking dumb. It's just dumb.
As back in the day when they had
a smoking section on an airplane,
you remember dice Clay's bed, you're
in a fucking tube. It's the same thing.
If you're talking about smoking or you're
talking about a fucking murder mystery.
How many God damn people could you
fucking kill on a plane. And you know,
somehow the fucking guys going to be
able to climb down into the luggage area.
It's gonna pull up some carpet
and there'll be a trap door there.
I must have flown on 9,000
fucking planes in my life.
Can somebody please tell me where that
fucking trap door is? It doesn't exist.
It's a separate fucking compartment.
It has to be.
And even if it isn't after nine 11 I'm
sure they fucking welded it shut, right?
They always show that movie. Somebody
goes down to visit their fucking dog,
right? And then there's some sweaty
Middle Eastern look and guy down there.
That's what they have now.
Back in the day,
it was some sweaty Russian looking guy.
It's whoever the fuck
were at odds with any,
they're always sweaty and they
need a shave and that down there.
And they have absolutely,
you know,
and they have absolutely no
fucking morals whatsoever.
And they're always down there
in the fucking luggage. Right?
And then he got the John McClane guy.
How many fucking guys have been on the
fucking plane? John McClain did one.
Then he,
Bruce Willis has been on the plane.
Wesley snipes has been on the always
bet on black mother fucker, right?
You thought that one was the last
one. He comes, oh, Liam Neeson.
Okay.
You know something?
Fuck air fucked movies on airplanes.
Okay.
Fuck all of them.
They all,
you name me one movie that took place
on a fucking airplane. That was good.
All right.
And I will immediately block you on
fucking Twitter for actually saying it's a
good fucking movie.
Okay?
You can fucking kill somebody
on the plane. But you know what?
Pretty much everybody's going to say it.
Are you going to do it?
Let's just say you had some little fucking
heart attack missed like the ice man.
Remember the ice man, they made a movie
about him. That guy where he would just,
he was sitting there talking about all
the murders he committed, you know,
talking through his clenched jaw.
Looks like an old sea captain,
but he was a fucking hit man for the mob.
He had dismissed.
He said he'd go into studio 54 and he'd
act those swishy and he'd walk up to a
guy, hit on him, and then
he'd spray him with this miss.
And like three seconds later the
guy would have a heart attack.
Let's just say you had the fucking iceman
cometh fucking heart attack missed.
All right,
now
you're in a row of three people.
Where do you think the best places to sit?
If you want to murder one of the
other two people in your row?
I'm guessing the middle seat.
Okay.
If I have to put this air quote caper
together and you'd take the fucking missed
and I'm going to fucking, I want to give
the guy on the window a heart attack.
I'm going to spray it in him and that
fucking guy is going to go into cardiac
arrest.
All right,
and do you think the guy sitting to the
right of me or the fucking lady to the
right of me in the aisle seat is not
going to notice this person convulsing?
All right, well let's just say they
fucking drop dead. It's so powerful.
They just dropped dead.
And just happen to slump
to the fucking side.
Now I might be able to get away with that.
All right?
But only if that person had already
had an already recline this seat.
Okay.
Hadn't already reclined their fucking
seat because when we go, you know,
we begin our initial descent,
the fucking stewardist or
the male stewardess is going
to fucking come over and
be like, excuse me sir, sir. Excuse me.
Could you wake him now I can't wake him
cause I fucking sprayed him with a heart
attack.
Missed.
What I can do is press the button forum
and put his fucking deadhead between his
fucking rigor mortis legs.
If you'd like Peter.
Otherwise name is Peter. All right, now
you killed one person. What the fuck you,
you're going to just start
going around killing people.
One person is going to die every 10
minutes unless I get a sack of cash in
Rhinelander Wisconsin to buy fucking two
30 you think the airline would give a
fuck?
All right.
$250 million ransom. Is that
what the fuck you want? I mean,
how much is it going to cost
them to settle out of court?
It's going to cost less than that
because they have all the money, right?
I don't like fucking movies
on airplanes and I don't like movies
where people have pointed ears and nobody
fucking addresses it. The other day
I'm sitting there with Verdesian,
we're flipping through the
fucking stations and one of
those hobbit movies comes
on and this fucking asshole, he's got one
of those, let it be seventies haircuts,
whereas hair is plenty long enough
to not show his fucking pointed ears,
but for some reason he's got it scooped
around the back of his ear like he's
gonna fucking blow somebody.
And I just look at, I go,
look at that dude's fucking ear.
How does the guy with the
white beard not address that?
Like what the fuck happened here?
What are you?
Huh?
You're fucking Elf. What does that
mean? What do you, what do you,
what does your diet consist of? Salary
and Guinea pigs. You fucking Weirdo.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Okay.
Is that, is that racist? Am I going
to have to apologize? The elves,
Jesus Christ.
Fucking God damn moves with airplanes.
You know what I mean?
Please, right? Oh please,
I don't have time for that sweetheart.
Okay,
let's get to some a advertising for this
week. Legal zoom.com, everybody. Um,
if the excitement of starting your
business, getting your first customer,
and finally quitting your job, it hasn't
moved you to action yet. You know what?
Nothing else will anyways.
I that why Improv that he says he,
the person said it could be a
woman who wrote this. She says,
here's another great reason
to get started. It's national.
Start Your business month slash get out
of your cubicle and start living for
yourself month slash
you can do it all right.
That legal zoom,
um,
and legal zoom wants to help you start
your own corporation or LLC or file your
DBA so you can get up. You can get
up and running quickly and easily.
Find out why more than 1
million entrepreneurs use
legal zoom to start down the
path of successful business
ownership this month,
this month only take advantage of their
national start your business month
special and get a free three month trial
of all new quickbooks making it so much
easier to run your new business.
That's $119 value. Everybody for free.
When you enter a burpee, you are
are in the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com Promo Code burr
legal zoom provides a self help services
and can connect you with the right
attorney, but they are not a law firm.
Promo Code burpee you
are are and the classics.
A stab start,
calm everybody.
Getting your mailing and shipping
done can seem like a no win situation.
Going to the post office
takes up valuable time.
I'm leasing a postage meter,
expensive with multiyear
commitments and hidden fees.
Luckily I happened to know a better
way and that better way has one name,
stamps.com everybody stamps.com with
stamps.com buy and print official US
postage for any letter or package right
from your desk using your own computer
or a printer even gets special postage
discounts you can find at the post.
You can't find that the post office
plus stamps.com is a more powerful,
it's more powerful than a postage meter
faster than a rolling over stronger than
silent e, um, at just
a fraction of the cost.
You can save up to 80% compared to the
postage meter and you'll avoid those time
consuming trips to the post office.
I use stamps.com just send out my DVDs,
my posters and any other crap that I sent
it to sell at the end of my show if I
can figure it out. Well, so can you right
now use my last name, birth for the spa.
This special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer,
which includes a digital scale
and up to 55 bucks free postage.
Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com
enter
bur that was brutal. Jesus
Christ. That was even bad for me.
Um,
okay.
No, the fuck am I. And why did that
just pop up? Why did that just pop up?
All right, let's get back to this over
here. Oh, Vov over here. All right.
Back to the podcast. So many ways.
I'm still up here in Canada. Oh,
Canada.
I'm touring across the provinces.
Um, I've had some people come in, I, um,
okay.
From some pretty crazy places.
A Yukon territory's,
somebody told me that there's a theater
up there. Maybe I'll look into that.
The next hour of bullshit that I come
up with the next time I talk Canada,
which I'm definitely gonna do.
Um,
I had someone fly in from Brazil and then
I had this couple coming from Kuwait.
Okay.
You know, and this, and they,
yeah, we flew all the way in,
but blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. And you know, we're going to hang
out here in Toronto, Yada, Yada, Yada.
And I said, wait a minute, I
go, could I do a show in Kuwait?
And they're like, absolutely.
And I said, I can say
what I said here tonight and
Kuwait and the guy goes, yeah.
And then the woman goes,
well,
but I'm just meeting those two.
I want to go there. You know,
they were some cosmopolitan motherfuckers.
I really would like to,
to the Middle East and not get kidnapped.
If you're in the Middle East and you know,
wear a fucking freckled white
boy from the u s can go,
you know, I would like to,
I want that middle ground.
I want to go to a place where I'm not
going to get abducted by people who
fucking hate my government.
And I also want to,
I don't want to go to a place that's
subsists because there's a tent city right
outside the city limits and people
are living a, you know, on dog food,
you got a middle ground that I can go to,
you know,
or I can do some fucking shows out there.
I can tell my jokes and I don't have
to worry about the Shah or the fucking
prime minister.
Oh,
the fucking son of the king of the Rab
are going to come in and take me away.
I don't want that to happen. I'd
like to go over there. Right.
I want to go on where,
on one of those coolest fucking
things on my head with the little, uh,
oh Robic Bandana.
I do that.
I do that in a fucking second.
Looking like a cornerback at the end
of the game with my fucking Doo rag on.
Let me know. I'll go over
there. I'll fucking doe it. Um,
oh hey, there's a rumor. I heard a rumor.
Jesus Christ. Who was that? Who Sang
that fucking shock wasn't Spandau Ballet.
I heard a rumor.
There was a z in it.
I'm calling that there
was a z in their name.
For some reason it was like three fucking
chicks and they will all almost good
looking. You know what
I'm talking about? Um,
I heard a rumor.
Lyrics.
Yeah.
Banana Rama. You motherfucker. Why
didn't I think there was a z in it?
Yeah.
Well,
you know what?
The fact that there wasn't a it and
the fact that I look the way I do and I
actually said that they were only
kind of good looking as punishment.
I now have to go to lyrics dot come and
sing as much as this is, I can remember.
I don't remember him.
Who needs a friend who never shows?
I'll tell you what you want to know.
I could have saved a broken heart.
Okay.
If I found out long ago,
I don't remember. I was,
I heard a rumor who,
Ooh,
I've heard of roof that's actually written
on it. Paper. I heard a rumor. Oh h.
O. O. H. Ooh, I heard a rumor.
They say you got it broken.
Then they know what now you guys
are getting punished. This isn't,
this isn't a punishment. You guys know I
like this thing even though I can't do,
you know some current wrote me one time
I was telling me how much I suck at
singing. Like I don't realize
that like that isn't the joke,
but you know something.
For those of you people who are about
to them on any sort of, uh, uh, a, uh,
a dream and it involves you having
a website or a Twitter account,
Facebook or anything,
uh,
anywhere where people
can give you feedback.
Just know that people will find
fucking something to bitch about.
Do you know what somebody said?
Somebody sent me a fucking
email or a Twitter thing.
I can't remember what it might have been
the most nit picky thing anybody's ever
said.
Okay.
When I was down in,
uh,
Hammer Ville there Hammerstein why can't
I remember the fucking name Hamilton
when I was down there?
You know,
at wire to wire had a fucking great
show. Go Fuck Yourself. I killed it.
Thank you for coming out.
I went out,
I fucking took pictures with people.
I'm selling what's left of my DVDs the
last time I'm selling a DVD because it's
one step ahead of the fucking laser disk.
I got to get him out of my garage.
Thank you to everybody who bought
one. Um, somebody actually said,
great show, but Jesus Christ,
your wallet is way too big.
Can you fucking believe that
out of fuck did you even see it?
I maybe have my back to the crowd for
fucking two minutes in an hour and 15
minutes set. And it bothered you
out big. My fucking wallet was,
it's not my fault.
It's stuffed with fucking business cats.
People give them to me when I'm on tour.
Hey, if you're ever a hair fucking,
this is this thing. If you'd ever
like some of this, here's this thing.
I just stuffed them in my wallet and then
when I come home I stick them with all
the other business cards that
I'm never going to look at. Okay.
And when you're in the middle of a 20
day toy, yeah. Can get a little bit big.
All right. Why don't you stop staring
at my fucking ass? You weirdo.
The middle of my show. You ever
think maybe that it's, it's,
it's so fat because it's stuffed with
the plastic money that I've made up here.
Do you know Canadian currency? Is, is uh,
the greenbacks that dollars are
they made out of plastic now?
Very smooth plastic and I fucking love it.
Their money is the shit.
I've always loved American money the
best because that's the money that I grew
up with and I just think it looks cool.
And I like all the weird
shit that don't with it,
with the extra big fucking heads.
They got a little off to the side,
little nod to hip hop, you
know, don't wear your hat
like Donnie baseball anymore.
You got to do fucking the Jay z thing or
it's off to the side just a little bit,
you know?
MMM.
What am I going to say?
What the fuck am I talking about yet?
But the only thing that stinks about
their money as I guess you can't stack it,
there's something about
it because it's plastic.
It just sort of slides down to
the side. But uh, but anyways,
that was the nitpick bitch or the week.
Evidently my wallet was too big,
you know, I really liked that standup
comedians act a was really funny,
but I got to tell you the size of his
bill fold just really ruined it for me.
You know what sir or ma'am, whoever the
fuck wrote me that I got to tell you,
you have, you have a future
as a critic. You really do.
Because even when critics like something,
they find something to fucking
complain about. You know,
even if they like your show, like my
show, even a good review, if you read it,
it would be like the big headed freckled
fuck took command of the stage for an
amazing performance of stand up as I
watched his distractingly alabaster hands
motion through brilliant bit after that.
That's what they do.
They're complimenting you while on salting
the shit out of how the fuck you look.
You know,
I don't like when they do that,
it'll kill you don't want to criticize
critics is another thing I don't like.
I don't like when fucking critics do
that or they writing an article on a
celebrity and they do that
thing where they fucking, uh,
they, they always get to talk about
what the fuck they're reading.
Cause I guess they always an
interview these movie stars and uh,
in restaurants and they
always get as shit,
say as he fucking bites into a pan seared
salmon and crusted pork chop and older
and wiser little fella from the fucking
angry king show there on HBO with this
tailored fucking suit. Okay. I Dunno.
He has a sadness in his eyes as
he bites into a cherry tomato.
I've really fucking hate that.
I just feel like they just did just
build it up. They're just like,
how many fucking words? So I got to
write about this little fella here. Ah,
would that dumb fucking look on his face.
I'm really sick of that fucking,
I'm just sick of the look on that
guy's fucking face. It's, it's,
I don't know what it is.
It's bad enough when a regular
size guy has that look on his face,
like he's going to come over there and
slap the taste. Study your mouth. Okay.
I don't need some little fella sitting
there with his little suit staring at me.
Like I said something about him. I
didn't say anything about you. Okay.
So,
you know,
why don't you get your fucking for Bra
and pointing in another direction and
fuck you and your cherry tomatoes.
What do you think about that? Huh?
Okay.
Again,
out of my face before I tip you over.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I really am in a country moote and this
APP has nothing to do with the little
fellow on the angry king show on Hbo.
It really has to do with the fact that,
uh,
I missed my wife and my dog.
I missed my truck, a mess,
all of that shit while simultaneously
having one of the greatest fucking tours
I've ever had been. Versie I haven't
so much fucking fun up here verse.
He started doing this fucking
Rodney Dangerfield impression.
So that's all we've been doing up here.
All we've been doing up here is
it will just be sitting there.
Okay.
You know, drinking a beer and you just go,
you know, hey, this is a good beer. No,
I'll tell you,
last week I had a rough one
and I don't know why.
It's always,
it's just been funny the
whole fucking week to us.
I've skated almost every God damn day.
These fucking,
you know what's great about
Canada because this so far north,
they have to embrace the winter and
there's just shit to do. They got like,
I like looked up free public skating here
in Toronto and you would've thought I
looked up a Starbucks, the amount
of fucking hits I got on my phone,
it's just fucking tremendous.
So you know,
there's only so long then I
can go on a God damn treadmill.
Yeah.
You know,
and with it just because you have the
option of just stepping off the fucking
thing. That's why I love my dog.
I love taking her on a hike,
going on a fucking hike, you
know, listen to some songs and I,
and I'm good boy, you're out here and you
fucking go out and you just go skating.
It's fun. So fucking good
time. Oh, you know what I did?
I got a friend of mine that lives up
here and he's an assistant coach on a,
on a hockey team. He's got a son
in the 10 to 11 year old group.
And I went to this rink,
they had four ranks.
They're all these different games and
I have to fucking tell you something.
I've never seen kids of that age play
the game the way these kids were playing.
They were fucking, it was an unbelievably
entertaining game. Was One. Nothing.
One, one, two, one, two, two and then
three, two and then they pulled the,
they got the dagger,
got the fourth goal and
these fucking kids up here.
Okay.
At Age 10 to 11 the level with
which they would play in this game.
It wasn't even the,
the kid with the Puck,
it was what the kids were doing away
from the park. How they knew where to be.
There was a fucking kid on the other team.
Last name,
kid number four or something.
I was like jealous how well
he could skate backwards.
This kid was like 10 or 11 years
old and the way you play defense,
I was actually watching him
learning. It was like, I dunno,
it was like an NHL gay, but everybody
was 10 or 11 like the way it was played.
Obviously, it wasn't as fast, but you
know, when I was watching it live,
I mean I couldn't really
tell. I was fucking blown away
by the talent up here. Um,
and it was a great game and when it was
three to two because the other team kept
tying it up,
I was actually on the of my seat
watching a game between 10
and 11 year olds. I mean,
it's fucking amazing up here.
So, um, anyways, I did that.
How far into the fucking podcast, Dan? My
Art, Jesus, I'm limping along this week.
29 minutes in.
Yeah.
You don't have been doing with Versie
this week. This is fucking, I've,
I've toured with Versie for so fucking
long. We're like an old married couple.
I've never seen anybody who hates
the morning as much as he does.
So this whole fucking tour,
I've never woken him up with a text cause
I always do that shit. I'll text them,
hey, you want to get breakfast?
And he's never quite awake.
So I just, I just wait till he fucking
wakes up and that, that fucking guy,
if you don't text him,
he will,
he'll sleep til like one in the afternoon
and he has still has the nerve to come
downstairs, look at a little groggy. He
always comes down like, God, how great.
How great was that mattress man?
Fucking epic at mattress was epic.
Everything's epic to him. Um, I dunno. So,
uh, that's why I'm doing the podcast
with dot. I'm next week we'll,
we'll wrap up the tour. We will wrap up
the tour. Uh, me and him will do the, uh,
the podcast together. Um, but
um, oh, I got to do another word.
I heard a rumor allegedly.
Okay.
They are, our dates in the works with
three of my best friends in comedy.
Quite possibly. I've heard rumors
that they might be doing a tour,
a club tour.
Okay.
That now maybe starting out
on the west coast, possibly.
Maybe starting in La, possibly
with yours truly hosting the show.
I've heard this fucking Romer
that possibly Rosebowl tailgate legends.
Jason Lawhead. Joe Barton. Nick.
Okay.
All right.
And Dude,
I called it Paul Versey quite possibly
could be doing a three man tour of clubs,
limited engagements
over the next couple of months,
sponsored by the Monday morning podcast,
the first tour.
I hope the first of many tours
to be sponsored by this podcast.
Um,
there are rumors that there are agents
right now working on over the weekend
suit on, tie off, wiping their brow,
trying to put together some
dates on this tour. Uh,
quite possibly next week there
might even be an announcement,
but right now that is just a rumor, but
I'll tell you what isn't a rumor. A,
I'm doing a date in Nashville on May 16th
and it's part of a Vince Vaughn's wild
west tour comedy tour.
And uh, let's see here.
I just fucking tweeted about it. Jesus.
Bill, what the fuck is wrong with you?
Hang on, hang on, hang on
you to home. No, I got to me
right? Yeah, the wild
west comedy festival,
Wild West Comedy festival.com is
the website tickets are on sale now.
Um, if you follow me on
Twitter, I have there,
I have their Twitter handle.
Is that what you say at wild west C F as
in comedy festival and on Facebook it's
facebook.com backslash WWC f Nashville
as in wild west comedy festival.
Uh, Nashville. Um,
anyhow. All right. So that's enough for
the goddamn promotions for the week.
Yeah.
Um, all right. Just when
you think my singing
can't get any worse,
how about I try to top that with sound?
You do you think I can
sound more dumb than,
than the level of my awful
singing while I think I can, uh,
I've been sort of keeping up on this,
this,
the events that are going on
over in the Ukraine and, uh,
with my limited knowledge of what's going
on there now and my limited knowledge
of what's happened there in the past.
Um,
okay.
That ousted fucking president or prime
minister or whatever they call them.
Okay.
Yannick Covich, that guy's
a sellout cunt. All right.
And I'm not trying to stir up
some shit over there. Okay.
But after what style and
did there and World War II,
they should want nothing
to do with Russia. Okay.
Okay.
The fact that there's Russian
sympathizers in the Ukraine.
I don't fucking get it.
Yeah.
Why does o Vladimir give a fuck
about this? Yana Covich so much.
I actually looked up, Yana Covich
Russian puppet and I got a bunch of hits,
so,
okay.
What gets you let the Ukrainians
have their own goddamn country?
They didn't like you so much
that they actually overthrew you.
There's so much dirty
shit going on over there.
I think Vladimir Putin or whatever the
fuck his name is. He said that, uh, that,
that that was actually,
yeah,
by the u s whether it be hilarious if we
actually back that if we back that they
overthrew their fucking prime minister,
whatever the fuck his name is.
Yanna Covich Anna Kournikova,
whatever his fucking name is. Right.
And then we get to go
publicly. It'd be like, Hey,
what are you guys doing in Russia?
Leave him alone.
Saad modeling in their affairs.
Okay.
If we actually did do it,
I have to respect all Vladi Vladi
daddy there that he fucking said.
Uh, he called us out on it.
I think he called us out on,
I remember he called somebody else out
on it. I would fuck knows, God knows we,
you know, you know we did something
over there. Hey, let me tell you,
it was a rough week over there and create,
um,
okay.
I Dunno,
just fucking leave him alone.
Can't countries just leave other
countries alone? But you know,
I think that'd be great for this country
if we just fucking pulled all our
people back.
We just left everybody alone and you know
what all our corporations had to come
back to and we started making Levi's
501 blues again. The button flies,
some z Cavariccis and we
actually made them here.
We didn't make children's sewn together.
You know, why can't we do that again?
And then you just legalize weed everywhere
and then you use that as the export.
And we got everybody fucking high
man and everybody mellows out.
Why can't we do that?
You know why?
Because everybody heard.
So the reason why you can't do it is
because it's the same reason why the
fucking NFL has that stupid ass fucking
dumb ass game in England every year.
All right? It's because of the
ego. You want to put your stamp,
you want to put your
fucking mark on something.
You want to say that it was here and
then I took it to here. You know,
no one could just be like,
hey,
we're right here and isn't this a good
place to be? He always got, what about me?
What about my fucking legacy? And
that's what, that's what the fuck.
And the guy from the NFL is doing.
All right,
Pete Roselle is the benchmark.
You got to somehow try to outdo him.
We went Pete Roselle and then Peter
Noone I think was the next fucking
commissioner. And then
you got this guy, uh,
was it Raykovich Roger Goodell.
I don't want the fucking guy.
He's name is bought out,
but he's got a somehow outdo Pete Rozelle.
Pete Rozelle brought the AFL and the
NFL together Monday night football,
the super bowl.
So the only way to top that is you somehow
after to try and go fucking global.
So he has that stupid ass dumb
ass fucking game in England.
Every God damn year for what?
Can't you just be happy being
billionaires are multimillion.
I would say that about everything.
I would say that about the fucking Nhl.
Why can't you just be multimillionaires?
Isn't that enough?
Why do you got to have the
Florida Panthers? Okay. And
you know what? Fuck you.
If you live in Miami,
fuck you. Okay? Fuck you.
You got all that exotic pussy down there.
You also have to have a fucking
NHL team. Go Fuck Yourself, okay?
You want to go to a hockey game?
You get and you goddamn VW bus
and you drive to a cold city.
All right?
I for one,
have had enough of these fucking
winter teams down in the fucking south.
All right?
Having a winter classic game
when a classic game at Dodger Stadium,
people sit there and fucking tank
tops watch an ice hockey outside.
All right? Now, I don't want
get all hippy on you here,
but how many porpoises had to fucking
die so they can fucking have enough God
damn water to make that
whole thing happened.
You know a lot of people don't realize
that ice is actually made out of salt
water. Okay. And salt water is
the living, breathing oxygen.
That poor processive inhales
through its fucking gills. Alright,
don't porpoise. A porpoise
is a mammoth. Are they?
And I realized that this oxygen and
water before you guys actually take that
shit seriously to porpoises
breathe through a porthole,
an orifice at the top of their head.
Okay,
I can look this up now. That's how
you spell porpoise. Poor poise.
Okay.
Is it a mammal? I spelt mammo
with three m's in the middle.
Did you mean mammal course? I
met Mammal Porpoise, mammal.
Any of the seven species of tooth whales
distinguishable from dolphins by their
row by they're more compact build,
generally smaller in size,
maximum length about two meters.
That's about 6.6 feet they
say and curved blunt snouts.
What's spatulate rather than
conical teeth. It was a great
word. Bachelor late. And Conoco,
I want you guys to you,
next time you get fucking hammered,
I want you to slip both of those words
in and if you can actually use them,
it's a great line to say to a
woman, you know, I like you.
I saw you from across the bar.
You know what really attracted me?
And she'd be like, what? And
you'd be like, you're blunt.
Snap with your spatulate
rather than conical teeth.
What would you like to drink,
sweetheart?
Blunt snout. That's a fucking good name
for a band. Maybe Jeremy Brown show.
Um, all right, let's, let's get to some
of the fucking questions this week.
I'm sorry, I, I'm just really
shitting the bed here. Um,
did I talk about everything?
I think I did. Oh,
people talking about the posters
where my posters relaxed.
They're all on their way.
Uh, we still got another,
there's still some more coming up this
week. Overwhelming response. And I got,
I got one guy in the mail room trying to
send all of these fuckers out, so, uh,
you'll get them all right. And they
are autographed. So relax. Okay.
And if you don't get them,
I'll give you fucking money back.
But I'm saying don't give up hope. All
right. Hang in there. Hang in there.
Stay gold. Pony boy. Stay gold. All
right. Baseball season. Billy Ruth.
I grew up loving the game of baseball.
My greatest memories. Hang on a second.
I got fucking close this window.
There's some dose talking
fucking muted. All right.
Hang on. All right. I grew up
loving the game of baseball.
My greatest memories as a child included
the smell of a Mitt and sensation of
throwing a ball hard across an infield.
I also grew up in an Orioles fan.
I'd fucking, Oreos were great when
I grew up and I was growing up.
They were the shit.
They were already.
They won in [inaudible] 66
and they want in 70. Uh,
they blew it and 79 and then
they won in [inaudible] 83.
Look at that right off the top of my
fucking head. But I can't read out loud.
Do you know I can do that?
And almost every sport.
I can go back to like the 60s and I
could tell you all the fucking champions.
66 the oriel 67 uh,
the cardinal speed,
the fucking red sox, 68 the
tigers want, and then they,
then they were having that fucking thing
while that, those riots and then the,
the,
the subsequent white flight that
happened and that cities never recovered.
69 the amazing mets,
73 oral 71 I think was the pirates.
And then Clemente died or the die.
And (727) 027-0370 four was the A's.
75,
76 was the red. 77, 78 was the Yankees.
79 was we are family.
The pirates,
80 Phillies,
81 was the fucking dodges,
right. Tommy John, Tommy,
John was on the fucking Dodgers
that lost to the Yankees. And 77,
78 a one,
he turned codes,
he goes to the fucking Yankees.
And what happens? The Dodgers win.
And that's why that
surgery's named after him.
82 was the cardinals.
A, they'd beat the brewers.
83 was the Orioles.
84 was the tigers.
85 was the royals.
It should have been the fucking
cardinals of the implode.
F that awful call at first
base 86 was the mets.
Red Sox fans know that 87 was the twins.
88 was fucking Kirk Gibson,
the Dodgers. I can just
keep going. People.
I could fucking go all fucking day long.
I know what you thinking.
You probably think I have in front
of them right in front of me. Well,
that's just a compliment. 89 was
the aids. The roid brothers want it.
Then 90 was the red. 91 of course
was you twins. 92 93 that was zero.
You're fucking Blue Jays and the
94 that's a great trivia year.
That was the strike here and if you
listen to fucking Pedro Martinez,
he'll sit there and tell you,
you know what,
the fucking expos we're going
to win that year. Why you ask?
Because they had a young,
him and Randy Johnson,
I think Tim Raines was still there
and a whole fucking great team there.
95 was the Braves. 96 was the
Yankees. 97 was the Marlin's.
They'd be j law heads,
Indians.
98 99 2000 was the fucking Yankees.
This is when he starts getting sketchy
for me. 2001 was the Diamondbacks.
2002 I think was the angels.
2003 was the Marlin's.
2004 was a red sox. 2005
was the white sox. 2006
was the fucking cardinals.
Was it 2007 was the red sox.
2008 was affiliate cause I was a 988 keys.
2010 was the Jane's then,
I don't fucking know.
2011 all right.
2013 was us.
The giants won another one in there.
Didn't they will say 2012 and
I'll say 2011 was the cardinals.
Oh my God. If you don't like
sports, you're in trouble now. Well,
let's go do football.
I could do it.
I can do hockey if you want.
I can go all the way back
to about 1966 I believe.
All right. Canadian Maple leafs,
Canadians, Canadians, Bruins, Canadians,
Rowan's Canadians,
flyers, flyers, Canadians,
Canadians, Canadians,
Canadians, islanders,
islanders, islanders, islanders,
fucking Edmonton, Edmonton. Canadians,
Edmonton, Edmonton, Calgary,
Edmonton
91 92 was at Pittsburgh.
93 was fucking
Montreal.
94 was the rangers.
95 was a devils.
96 was the avalanche.
97 98 was it fucking
[inaudible]
99 was Dallas stars.
Why are you guys listening to this?
2000 was the fucking avalanche.
No. Was it devils 2001 report.
Avalanche thousand two fucking
Devil's 2003 if I can read links,
maybe lightning strike ducks.
Hurricanes.
All right, sorry, I'm back.
Let's read this thing here. Um,
I also grew up in an Orioles fan too.
That was fucking add textbook right there.
I love the oriels and I
love Major League baseball,
but why can't I get the baseball,
get into the baseball season?
It has nothing to do with my
team. Oh, I read that wrong.
But why can't I get into the baseball
season? It has nothing to do with my team.
I was happy for the socks,
but it's just hard to get excited about
the sport and I desperately want to.
Is there a greater reason I'm missing?
Uh, well, I mean,
it kind of sucks that there's no
salary cap and that, you know,
the red sox can afford to spend a buck
80 a year and the fucking Yankee you
spend like two 20 a year.
Um,
so I mean,
essentially between the two of them
sang on a second.
I mean,
one of us is going to win the fucking
division probably 80% of the time.
I mean,
if you go back to 1996 the first
time the Yankees won the division.
All right.
And that wasn't because they spent money.
That was because George Steinbrenner
gets suspended and he wasn't allowed to
fucking metal. And He, I
swear to God he wouldn't, he
wouldn't trade it away. Jeter.
MMM,
definitely. What a terrier
way. Bernie Williams,
probably Jorge Posada and
I bet even Marianna Rivera,
just because nobody knew he hadn't
developed that cut fastball yet.
No, he probably, he probably keep
like to have them pick two of them.
He definitely get rid of Andy Pettitte.
He fucking was up that guy's ass
even when he was crushing it.
MMM.
But anyways, I dunno, somewhere
around 98 99 it's just,
it's just become like
ridiculously all about money.
And I would say from there on,
if the red sox didn't win at the Yankees,
wanted to maybe Tampa
Bay when it one year,
I can tell you right now, the Orioles
have in fucking one. It's since,
I dunno when the 80s maybe early
nineties I have no fucking idea.
I would say that that's
kind of what makes it suck.
MMM.
I don't understand why all
leagues aren't run like the bike,
NFL football where Green Bay Wisconsin
can compete with New York City.
It's great.
It's a great thing.
So I would say that maybe that's why
you can't get into the regular seasons
because a lot of times by June,
what's the fucking point?
MMM.
And the great thing about the Orioles,
I mean, you guys had said that,
that great tradition there.
MMM.
You know, when in three world
series, essentially my lifetime,
I was born in 68 so I
don't remember 66 or 70,
but I remember 83 and I just remember he
had all those great pictures when I was
growing up. Frank Tenana, Jim Palmer.
MMM Nah,
fuck. There was another one
that you guys always had the,
had like three number ones and you're
starting rotation. You guys were brutal.
Eddie Murray at first base fucking,
I don't,
can't remember the other names. Who
the fuck knows? But it was great.
It was great to watch it catch.
It was hilarious.
Why do I think it's Doug to Sensei wasn't
any play third base for the fucking
angels. Um, that's probably
why he can't get into it.
You probably can't get into it because
it's not a level playing field. It's a,
um, I dunno, I dunno
what to tell you. Sorry.
Just sort of fucking space
to halfway through that. All
right. Childhood crush us.
Billy Suave. Uh, when you were
growing up in the late seventies,
what celebrity ass would you have banged
if you had the choice? Well, I mean,
I was fucking like six
years old. So was I, I was,
I supposed to take out my little
Schmeichel is the Jewish people say, um,
I don't know what I would've done with it.
I'm a Charlie's angel
or perhaps Stevie Nicks.
Who are you into? And was there someone
that everyone was into that you couldn't,
why? Um, Oh man, I
fucking, I loved everybody.
I loved all three Charlie's angels.
I probably liked Farrah Fawcett.
She's the one I wanted to bang. Kate
Jackson was the one I wanted to marry.
And, uh, I liked, I liked Kate Jackson
when she was on the rookie sneeze.
She's a fucking nurse. She was married
to Mike Danco. What a fucking name,
Huh?
Mike Danco.
She had that great voice. Ah, man.
She was beautiful. And, uh, you know,
Jacqueline Smith, Matt Jaclyn Smith, she
had the same haircut is fair fosters,
except it was a Brunette.
I've always liked brunettes.
Um, so I liked all of them.
Okay.
And then I liked Kristy
McNichol much to her chagrin.
Uh,
who else?
Okay.
I fucking like the mall. Trying to
think of another show I used to watch.
Yeah.
I like Marsha Brady.
You know,
when she got a little bit older and was
wearing those fucking mini skirts, um,
even Jan a couple episodes, she
hoarded up pretty good for a young May.
I liked that.
Um,
okay.
Joanie, from happy days when
she got older, you know,
was taken a few from Scott bail.
I liked her then.
Okay,
let's see.
Welcome back Kotter.
And that was a bunch of don'ts except
for his wife. I wasn't into her though.
Yeah.
Uh, what else? Boat bad. Dope. Do,
what else did I used to watch?
Welcome Bay. This is when, you know,
you watched it a lot when you could
actually sing the second verse. Yeah.
Always could spot of friend,
but Pampa Bull.
Welcome back to that southern and
dissolve them. Better. Bad at blue.
All right. I only could sing
the first fucking line. Um,
okay.
Was that it?
I think that was it.
I had a very sheltered childhood.
There was only like three channels.
MMM.
That wasn't a big radio guy.
I was too fucking young.
Like I only reason why I knew about kiss
was a couple of my friends had older
brothers and one of my friends is really
good at drawing and he would drum,
you know, all the kiss characters
and I had no fucking idea.
My parents didn't take me to see
star wars had no fucking idea,
so I had no crush on prince slayer.
I remember that Shit.
That shit came out over the summer
and I didn't even hear about it.
I went outside,
I played baseball every fucking day.
I went down to the pool
and I went swimming. No,
we weren't even members
of the pool at that point.
They had like a community pool slash piss
tank that we will lose our members of.
Yeah. I just went outside and I played
every day, go outside and play, went out.
We rode bikes and played baseball.
We did what kids did back then and
that's why we weren't fat kids.
We fucking went outside there. You, I
would say, yeah, the Charlie's angels.
I wasn't into to the bionic woman.
Okay.
I didn't get into her.
God Damn it.
I thought there was way more than that.
Okay.
I know there was, I just
can't remember anymore. Um,
but was there anybody who everybody was
into and I couldn't understand it? Uh, no.
No I couldn't.
Okay.
I thought they were all fucking beautiful.
I really did.
Fucking women in the late seventies.
They will fucking go Cheryl Tiegs
I don't fucking remember. They were all
gorgeous. I remember every magazine cover.
It was a woman on the cover. Even I was
a little kid. You had a crush on her. Um,
childhood crushes. Right. I just
read that one. A instruments bill.
I'm 14 years old. I suspect I'm
one of your younger listeners.
I'm growing to learn how
to play a new inch. Oh,
I'm going to learn how to play
a new instrument this year.
I already played piano and love
the progressive nature of drums,
but I also want to be
able to shred a solo.
Any suggestions to which would be better
to start? Definitely stick with piano.
Okay.
All right.
There they have more fucking piano
sitting around than anything else. Okay.
So your whole life, if you can just sit
down and just start playing a piano,
women will come over to your piano.
All right.
Like flies to a few moths to a light.
That's a great one to learn how to play.
So definitely don't even Tommy Lee said,
I wish I stuck with it.
MMM.
You got to stick with
the piano. Uh, um, uh,
obviously prejudice to drums,
drums of this shit. Um,
but if you don't shred a Solo,
I dunno,
you know what, maybe guitar,
Guitar and drums are great.
Those are both Badass instruments.
And Piano I said is this very
social thing your whole life,
you'll be able to sit down,
all right. Attract women.
And then when you become
married and you become a father,
you can sit around playing the piano.
Oh, you know, Dad [inaudible] Dad,
Sarah pred.
Oh my keys playing the piano,
gather round children,
God and Cupid Donner and bled.
Said, you know, you can do
your own little jazzy version,
but do you Rico? Um, yeah.
But either way, I'm good on you for
learning an instrument, you know,
and not becoming a Dj, even though that's
now acknowledged as a a an instrument.
Yeah.
You want to be able to actually
fucking do it. I don't give a fuck.
Those djs are amazing that they can take
little sounds and make it into a song,
but at the end of the fucking day, you
know, they're cutting and splicing.
Okay.
They're more like editing an album
while creating, if the same time,
which I'm not going to lie you.
It's very impressive. All right?
But there's nothing cooler than,
than actually being able to play
the sounds that those miles had.
People are fucking sticking
together once you agree. Um, yeah.
Drums or coolest shit.
Okay.
I don't know what to tell you,
but you already play piano, man.
So you've got that ear. Yeah. Guitar.
I would try. I would try them out,
but don't give up playing the piano, man.
That's a great one. A great one to play.
Unless you're in a heavy metal band
and they're all fucking rocking out and
you're sitting there with the keyboard.
That's a tough one.
That was always a tough one.
There's always a tough one to try to
fucking Headbang when you're behind a
behind a fucking keyboard.
Oh,
we're halfway there, right?
Those guys in journey.
I'd actually like to learn how
to play the piano, you know,
but I just have too much sympathy
for my wife. I wouldn't do it. Hey,
let me tell you,
I can play drums with channel this.
I'll tell you us a little
rough. Um, boyfriend cheated.
Oh wait, before we get into this, let me,
let me read the last advertisement here
for the week. Um, he voice everybody.
You are a business owner,
but automated phone systems
and secretaries aren't
in your budget just yet.
And juggling incoming calls yourself
makes it hard to look like a professional.
Here's something that will dramatically
help you, help you and make more.
But here's something that will
dramatically help you make more money.
In 2014 he voice whether you're a business
of one or 100 he voice will help you
manage all of your incoming calls
with a toll free number, dial by name,
directory and call routing tools. Your
business will sound like 1 million bucks.
Can't take a call. He voiceful transcribe
the voicemail and email it to you.
Never be caught off guard again and with
the voice you can try it before you buy
it right now.
Just for my listeners,
you can get a 60 day trial to
he voice for absolutely free.
Excuse me.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the
Promo Code Bill B I l l at the checkout.
Take charge of your business and make
more money in 2014 go to [inaudible] dot
com and enter bill at checkout for
your 60 day free trial. That's easy.
voice.com Promo Code Bill.
All right, there you go.
I realize another reason why I suck so
bad at fucking reading is because my mind
goes to other places and really
understanding how my fucking brain works.
I literally got halfway through
reading that and I started thinking,
what pictures am I going to post this
week from my Canadian Tor, Tor. Tor.
Okay. Boyfriend cheated
bill. I'm a 25 year old girl.
You are a woman lady. All right.
Don't sell yourself short.
You're a woman. I found out my boyfriend
was cheating on me. The truth is I'm sad,
but at the same time I get that we're
not meant to be together forever. Um,
can you please suggest a fun way for me
to break up with him just in a way that
makes him feel like he
did something wrong,
but also feel like less
of a man if possible.
Love to you and the all right.
Um,
yeah.
All right. Well first of all, you know,
you don't seem too broken up about it.
It's 25 years old. All right?
You're in the prime of your life.
MMM,
Jen. You're like, wow, we're not going to
be together anyway. So this guy broke up.
How can you break up with
them? Ah, Jesus. You know what?
Women are way better at this than I am.
Okay. Break up in a way that makes them
feel like he did something wrong. Well,
I mean, you could just say
it. I'm breaking up with you
because you cheated on me,
you piece of shit, but also make
them feel like less of a man.
All right, well, you know what?
I'm going to put that on you,
but don't go the usual hacky ways that
women go where they usually say he didn't
satisfy me a bed. Do you
have a little Dick? You know,
I don't go out and go fuck
one of his friends because
eventually you ready Brett,
that that's just another notch
on your fucking bed post.
Unless you really want
to bang one of them.
Okay.
That's a really brutal thing to do.
That fucking breaks up their friendship
and you don't give a shit. Right.
Okay.
Um, I don't know what to tell
you. What could you do? All right,
let's see if someone did that to me.
Makes you feel like you did something
wrong and make what would make me feel
like less of a man.
Yeah.
Why don't you just break up with them
and then I guess you got to go the hacky
route and just say, oh, by the way,
and then just pointed his dick and
just start laughing hysterically.
I Dunno. Maybe you'll come
off as a psycho that way.
Why don't you get him a
cake? Oh Jesus. Oh Man.
I almost don't want to even tell you
to fucking do this. This is brutal.
I get it. Is his birthday coming
up? If his birthday is coming up,
you take them out to a
restaurant and yeah. Yeah.
Have him bring a cake over or maybe
you have your friends to work because I
don't think the restaurant, we'll do
it and he thinks it's a birthday cake.
All right.
And it says in frosting.
MMM,
you cheated on me. You
piece of shit. Okay.
And then you have your friends if they
can sing and they'll just sing the happy
birthday song with new lyrics.
Why did you cheat on me?
You do. Why did you cheat on me? You do.
You do each bag.
Why did you cheat on me?
And he's got a big fucking candle shape,
like a dick.
Maybe funny if it's more of a limp Dick.
I don't know. Maybe something like that.
Yeah.
Hey look, I tried. What
do you want from me? Okay.
I want to tell you how it was
kind of rough. Um, anyway.
Ah, fuck. Um, all right. So tonight
I am, I want to thank, first of all,
I want to thank everybody, uh, who,
who's been coming out to my shows, this,
this tourism. And I know I sounded kind
of crabby and tired today, but, uh,
I'm having a great time and as a public
rink down the street and I want to go
skate around and get the fucking blood
going before I drive out to a London,
Ontario tonight,
I got Montreal next and then I got
my day off where we're going to, uh,
the Canadians and a Bruins game.
And then that's the end
of the east coast swing.
And then we started our west coast swing,
which will be Winnipeg,
Edmonton, Calgary, uh, fucking Vancouver.
And then that little peninsula out
there, whenever the fuck it's called, um,
I dunno, whatever. Dude.
I'm fucking out of it.
I need an,
I didn't want to go skating
and then I'm gonna take a nap,
but I'm going to fucking
kill it tonight in London.
That is the game plan. I just threw
my hat down. Did you hear that?
Throw it down. Get myself psyched
up for the shoulder night.
That's the podcast for this week.
Thank you to everybody
who's come out to my shows up here.
I got to tell you man,
don't sleep on Canada and come
up here during the winter time.
It's fucking great if you'd like to.
That's a,
that's actually a great way to learn how
to enjoy the winter and come to Canada
in the winter. You don't actually talk
to somebody and they, they, you know,
I was saying how, you
know, I always wanted
the fucking build a rink in my
backyard for my kids that I don't have.
And um, this guy was like,
oh yeah, I did it. You know,
they all had these different techniques
on how to make the ice perfect and they
build these little ass fucking rinks for
their kids and then tear him down and
reassemble them every fucking year. It's
a, they're, they're amazing people, man.
Really Fun people up here
and great goddamn food.
The only thing that I'm going to bitch
about is in Toronto was sitting there,
we bought these Cuban cigars and there's
no fucking place to smoke up standing
on a heat lamps like assholes freezing
our asses off during to smoke these
cigars. Man, there's not
one cigar bar and uh,
and all of Toronto.
And something sad I
notice happened up here.
I finally went to the El Mocambo last
night cause I wanted to have a drink
because that's where a Stevie ray Vaughan
and double trouble had this great live
DVD that they did and I always wanted
to go into, it's a great dive. Uh,
all these people have played
their fucking, you know,
the rolling stones did a
show there in like 1977.
It's a really famous place and I
went over there and it's closed.
It's actually for sale and people
are kind of holding their breath,
hoping that someone is going to buy it
and refurbish it and keep the legend
going.
And I took a picture of it,
the melancholy look on my
face last night and uh,
I wish I had a chance to go in there,
but I'm hoping that someone's going to
buy it and keep it going. Cause I, I, I,
that was one that was on my bucket list
and I fucking blew it last time I was
here. I could have gone in there and I
just got too fucking busy. I blew it.
Anyways, that's the podcast for
this week. Go fuck yourselves.
I will talk to you next week.
I'll let you know about the rest of the
tour and the upcoming possibly Joe Bart,
Nick, Jason Law had Paul Versey. It's
just a rumor, but what I bring it up,
if it wasn't going to be a fact till the
next week and find out it was a rough
road.